De las pocas cosas buenas que hizo
el congreso de la República,
este año es una ley
que prohíbe el uso de animales de la fuerza pública
en manifestaciones.
Está a punto de ser ley,
está a punto de ser firmada por el Presidente.
Aquí en el observatorio animalista
le contamos la relevancia histórica y jurídica
que tiene esta norma.
Colombia, después de siglos,
se opone expresamente a utilizar a los animales,
a los caballos y a los perros
como elementos disuasorios de la fuerza pública.
Y no es algo menor,
el mismo Cristóbal Colón llegó con estas ideas,
perros de casa,
para destrozar vivos los cuerpos de los indígenas
y de paso ejercer efectos disuasorios en ellos.
Por su parte, Sebastián de Val. Alcázar,
como gobernador de Popayán,
también lo podemos contar
como uno de los primeros registros de conquistadores
que utilizaban estas prácticas.
Pasaron los siglos y ya siendo República Colombia,
en su primer código penal en 1 837,
promulgó un artículo
que hablaba de animales peligrosos
y estableció todo un delito
al que le produjera lesiones graves a otro
valiéndose de un animal humano.
Pasaron siglos
y se dejaron de considerar potencialmente peligrosos
algunos de los animales.
Con la ley 20,
54 del 2 020, claro está,
hace muchos años también se dejaron de utilizar como
armas por parte de la fuerza pública,
pero seguían y siguen como elementos disuasorios,
colocando en grave peligro sus integridades
físicas y emocionales
de los animales allí presentes
en protestas y manifestaciones.
Luego Del estallido social,
con protestas y evidencias de estos abusos,
empieza un proyecto de ley en el congreso
para darle fin a estos actos de maltrato.
Todo esto por iniciativa del congresista liberal
Juan Carlos Lozada,
el concejal de Medellín, Juan Jiménez Lara
y organizaciones como animal defender internacional,
Adi alto y animal naturales.
Pasaron los debates y gracias a ellos
hoy estamos a días de que el Presidente
Gustavo Petro firme
sancione y ponga fin a una historia de abusos
y abra de paso la reflexión
para futuras acciones reales
en defensa de los animales en el país